Killian Mbappe sera-t-il encore au Paris
Saint-Germain la saison prochaine depuis
deux jours c'est un air de divorce qui
flotte entre l'attaque en français et le
club parisien en 2022 Mbappé qui avait
en effet signé un contrat de 2 ans avec
le PSG accompagné d'une option pour la
saison 2024-2025 ne va probablement pas
activer cette option lundi l'équipe
rapportait que le capitaine de l'équipe
de France on a informé ses dirigeants
dans une lettre une lettre qui n'a pas
pu assez même dirigeants alors que le
meilleur joueur de la dernière saison de
Ligue 1 devait donner sa décision au
plus tard le 31 juillet or mardi Mbappé
a confirmé qu'il les avait déjà informés
de sa décision en juillet 2022 le joueur
de 24 ans prétend qu'aucune éventuelle
prolongation n'a été évoquée alors que
des sources proches du club confirmaient
mardi au Figaro que des discussions
autour d'une prolongation avait été
menée s'il s'agit clairement d'un duel
comme contrecom et qu'on ne sait pas qui
dit vrai et qui dit faut le désaccord
affiché en place publique n'augure rien
de bon dès lundi des sources proches du
PSG mettez les choses au clair soit
qu'il y a une battait prolonge soit
Paris cherchera le vendre des cet été en
effet pas question de les laisser partir
en 2024 au terme de son engagement et ce
sans indemnités de transfert impossible
au vu de la situation économique du PSG
et des contraintes s'imposées par le
gendarme financier européen mais les
conséquences avec ou sans Kilian Mbappé
ne sont pas les mêmes pour Paris
économiquement sportivement mais aussi
en terme d'image d'API être au centre de
l'avenir du projet parisien la pierre
angulaire du club avait avoué nasseral
relayfi le président du PSG le départ de
Mbappe star mondial du foot serait aussi
un coût économique très dur pour la
Ligue 1 la Ligue de Football
Professionnel visant aux alentours du
milliard d'euros en droit TV confié son
président Vincent Labrune dans un
entretien à l'équipe mais aussi qui pour
remplacer Mbappé et quel club pour
l'acheter dès cet été pour la somme
d'environ 160 millions d'euros évalués
par le Centre international d'études du
sport sur les réseaux sociaux
l'attaquant à réaffirmer qu'il voulait
continuer à jouer au PSG la saison
prochaine ajoutant à être très heureux à
Paris ce n'est pas la première fois que
les velléités de départ de Mbappé font
surface dès l'automne le buteur français
aurait fait part de ses doutes quant à
la qualité de l'effectif parisien une
information qu'il avait démenti mais
attention ces informations qui mettent
en jeu sans aucune mesure des sommes
d'argent pharamineuses et le mercato
habituel sont à prendre avec précaution
la vérité d'un jour n'est pas forcément
celle du lendemain
[Musique]